[Music]
and she's getting you out of hard water
[Music]
well we've never had a visit from fish
and wildlife before because our
sanctuary has a perfect record
i'm sure whatever it is we'll be able to
sort it out oh can i for you something
i'll take a coffee
what i can't ask for a coffee
it's not about your sanctuary oh
okay
phew we have reason to believe a hitman
has been hired to murder you
oh what what does the name joseph
maldonado passage mean anything to you
oh my god jesus christ
joe hired a hit man
yes
joe can afford a hit man
mrs baskin do you know why mr maldonado
passage would engage a murder for hire
yes he is a psychopath who wishes me
dead we've been in an ongoing dispute
with joe
has he been charged we hope to have
enough evidence to charge him soon
and um
where is the hitman
we can't locate him at the moment
he lost the hitman
last we heard he was leaving oklahoma
mm-hmm and where was he going
here
here
huh
well i
i'm sorry i understand this must be very
hard for you
what
oh no sorry i just didn't take my
medication yet today i'm i'm allergic to
cats
so i i assume that you two are here to
guard the house then
that's not really something we do at the
fish and wildlife service
well what's the plan
we recommend you take precautions
i don't i i don't understand i'm sorry i
don't understand so what you're saying
is that someone is currently on their
way here to murder me
and
there's nothing you can do about it
we thought
you should know
uh
[Music]
when she